أَنَا أَنَا الأَسَدْ
أَسَدْ
أَنَا الأَسَدْ مَلِكُ الغَابَةْ
ذُو إِقْدَامٍ وَمَهَابَةْ
إِنِّي أَقْوَى الحَيَوَانَاتْ
تَحْسِبُ لِزَئِيرِي حِسَابَا
أَنَا الأَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ أَنَا الأَسَدْ أَنَا الأَسَدْ أَنَا الأَسَدْ
أَنَا الأَسَدْ
بِزَئِيرِي أَهُزُّ الأَدْغَالْ *** فَيَفِرُّ الكُلُّ وبِالحَالْ
أَحْيَا مِنْ حَوْلِي لَبُؤَاتِي *** تَلْهُو مِنْ حَوْلِي الأَشْبَالْ
أَسَدْ أَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ أَسَدْ أَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ
أَنَا مُفْتَرِسٌ أَنَا صَيَّادْ *** ومِزَاجِي لَوْ أَغْضَبُ حَادْ
أَتَجَوَّلُ أَرْضَ السَّافانَّا *** مَعَ عَائِلَتِي كَالْمُعْتَادْ
أَنَا الأَسَدْ مَلِكُ الغَابَةْ *** ذُو إِقْدَامٍ وَمَهَابَةْ
إِنِّي أَقْوَى الحَيَوَانَاتْ *** تَحْسِبُ لِزَئِيرِي حِسَابَا
أَسَدْ أَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ أَسَدْ أَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ
أَنْيَابِي ضَخْمَةْ وقَوِيَّةْ *** أُخْضِعُ لِي تِلْكَ البَرِّيَّةْ
لَكِنْ عَائِلَتِي الأَصْلِيَّةْ *** وَفَصِيلَةَ جِنْسِي القِطَطِيَّةْ
أَسَدْ أَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ أَسَدْ أَسَدْ  أَنَا الأَسَدْ